foreign
by the way the news stations do not care
about you they want your clicks and they
want your attention they want you to
keep spending your money they don't care
about you politicians don't care about
you they want to keep their jobs and
their power to keep on spending your
money that is it
[Music]
hey what's up this is John with the Dr
John deloney show show about mental
health and parenting and marriage and
dating whatever is going on in your
world
things have fallen apart
you show up here and I'll sit with you
I'll bring some some nachos I'll uh
bring a drink and we'll we'll figure out
what to do next
um here's what this show is for this
show is for folks
who want to see inside somebody else's
life so that they can use what's going
on in somebody else's story
and apply it to their own life
this show is real callers real people
going through real junk in their lives
and my commitment I don't always know
the answer
sometimes I'm on the phone calling
experts all across the country
um for their insights and wisdom but my
promise is I'm going to sit down I'm
going to tell the truth the best I know
it and if I don't know I'm gonna say I
don't know
um
but we've got to do life a different way
we just have to I mean I was more
convicted this weekend
um we had a group of people over to our
house for Easter celebration and it was
just a group of incredible Misfits it
was so great all these different
families from all these different places
all from all over
wherever who landed at our house out in
the woods and this reminded me there's
another way there's another way and so
that's what this show is for is giving
you some insights and we have Brave
callers from all over the world calling
into the show asking about what's going
on in their life and they helped paint a
picture for how you can be a better mom
be a better dad get new insights into
your mental health challenges figure out
what to do next with your nutrition diet
whatever's going on whatever is going on
so if you want to be on the show give me
a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a s k
um and please share these shows with
everybody everybody you know everybody's
going through something be that person
who just was always shooting the text
with the with the link to it or shoot an
email with a link to it
um please hit the subscription
um and or go to iTunes or YouTube
wherever you're consuming this thing and
hit the thumbs up button or the
subscription however it works on the on
whatever internet platform you're using
so super super grateful for you all
right let's go out to Sean in Richmond
Virginia what's up Sean
Dr John how are you partying man what
are you up to
oh man
um just fanboying right now
um I am fanboying too I'm a fanboy too
what's up man I'm uh all right so I'm
been using your your cards for humans uh
to better build my relationship with my
kids how's that working now or my
six-year-old oh it's great my
six-year-old is coming to me now asking
what's the best part of my day and
what's the most challenging part of my
day wow that's incredible man good for
you
yeah so my question is how do I uh best
integrate my kids into another family of
kids
um I live in one of these awesome states
that make you stay separated for 12
months before finalizing divorce God
knows how long how much longer later
after that
um but uh did you did your attorney tell
you why they do that
I can't think of a dumber law that's not
true there's we've got plenty of dumb
laws and I'm in Tennessee so we are
we're trying to just like hold my beer I
can make an even dumber one but like I I
just don't understand that at all I just
don't understand it though but okay so
12 months okay so yes is your divorce
not finalized yet
not yet
um are you already dating
I I'm not a dating uh but I do have
someone that I am very you know curious
to see what's going to happen once the
divorce is final yeah it's kind of kind
of like a middle school like we're not
going out we just like make out that's
cool Facebook officials exactly oh geez
okay so
um tell what happened with your with
your marriage
um it was one of those where uh honestly
was a lack of communication on both ends
um I was growing one way and she was
growing another way and our picture of
our future changed individually and we
never really sat down to repaint that
picture
um so it just kind of fell apart from
there and I tried to
do what I could to help better myself to
be a better husband better father
um and
you know she just wasn't uh wasn't into
it so
um I want to do marriage counseling and
uh she did not and that kind of told me
everything I needed to know there
who ultimately filed on who
uh we both sat down and said you know we
just need to
end it and both agreed okay
um
so were how many months ago was was the
final
you all sat in a room and said this is
let's just be let's be done
uh about
10 months ago okay and then how long
before that how many years has it been
pretty chaotic and frustrating
two to three years beforehand okay and
then how old are your kids
uh eleven and six
okay
and so the person that you're not you're
not Facebook official yet you're just
like
um uh tell me about them
uh she has three kids
um
ages 5 12 and 15.
um she's a freaking superhero in my book
she's raised those kids by herself
um she's an ER nurse
um so she lives in chaos and she still
finds ways to smile and laugh every
single day
Okay so
tell me your question
um what like best practices for
uh introducing and kind of integrating
the kids together okay
um so there's a couple of big rocks here
and then I'll I'll let you speak into
some of it
um one of the big rocks is
just to hold in your back pocket is
don't ever introduce somebody to your
kids that you don't see a long-term
connected future with
right
um there's this there's kind of an uh
there's an idea floating around out
there that I hear a lot which is I need
to I need to show my kids that I'm
moving on past this hurt and that I'm
out dating again I want to I want to
provide a good picture of what dating
looks like
kids are desperate for one word in this
season stability
stability stability stability so before
you bring somebody else in
establish some routines on this is how
life is gonna go
and let there be some smoke clearing on
let those kids know this is their new
life
and then
six months down the road a year down the
road when you're convinced that This
Woman's a rock star and she's going to
be your next whatever and you thought
communication was hard last time but now
let's marry somebody's video ER drama
nurse with three kids
um one of which you will be driving by
then let's do that so we're going to
have established great communication and
then you're gonna Circle back and slow
so that's number one is
let there be some space make this make
sure this person is like no no I see a
legitimate future here the second thing
is this stability as I talked about
um and by the way that doesn't mean
normalcy there is no normal like the kid
for the kids it's oh just can't it's
chaos so we're gonna provide some
stability we're gonna have some routines
we're gonna have some this is the way
this is
um and I think it's important for you
you've been ready for this for years
right
and right now this woman that you're
talking to may have been talking to how
long have you been talking to her for
two years three years ten months we've
known each other for about 10 years okay
um so she's not like uh she's not a
stranger she's someone that um I do
trust very much and I know very well
um when did you have feelings for
and be honest probably about
three months ago okay that was the first
time you've been like uh maybe
yeah yeah after 10 years come on Sean
I've always been like good friends had a
really good connection from the
beginning
um
and yeah it's just kind of one of those
things where it's like yeah this is what
I what I've been missing okay I I can't
emphasize this enough that as good as it
feels to finally have what feels like in
your life
um like a partner someone on the same
team someone who laughs at the same
things you laugh at whatever you have to
wrap your head around the fact that this
is still very much a fantasy
still very much a because it's not this
so you've established three or four big
rocks that aren't what you had and she
happens to have those three or four
rocks and the challenges or the the the
fantasy part is there's three or four of
the rocks that you that you had with
your ex that you don't even realize that
this new person doesn't have
so it's not a matter of I finally found
what I'm looking for as great U2 song
says it's not that it is I'm finally
deciding that I can live with these and
I'm gonna I'm going to honor these right
it's it's it's not going to be an even
trade like you think it is right now and
that's the importance of just slow
playing it because you're still
you're still so happy to be out of one
and oh my gosh she thinks I'm funny my
ex-wife didn't think I was funny at all
so I was annoying right
um and then I think dude this is super
important
often often often often kids
when they are being introduced to Mom or
Dad's new boyfriend or girlfriend
they feel a sense of disloyalty to their
birth parents on the other side
as though if I accept dad's new
girlfriend
I'm betraying mom
and
if you and your ex were able to sit down
and be super transparent with one
another probably in a way that if you
hadn't been it would have saved your
marriage originally and say you're gonna
date again I'm gonna date again we have
to be in communication because your wife
may bring home some scumbag that you
don't want around your kids that's
number one and vice versa and number two
you need your your ex to say to your
kids and they come home and say dad's
got a girlfriend that her first words
are I'm so glad dad's happy
not tell me about her
because there's going to be that that
seed plant does that make sense
yes if that can't happen and it can't
happen in most divorces because again if
people were that much adults they could
have dealt with this way up Upstream
um you just have to be prepared for that
and then when it comes to like actually
joining up and you're talking about your
two kids suddenly being outnumbered in
their own house
and so I would definitely if you all
decide one day we're gonna we're gonna
get married we're gonna lock this thing
up that you would get
um some professional counseling to help
integrate here's what this new family is
going to look like we get to create this
sucker kids mom dad everybody we're
gonna create what this thing looks like
one of the kids is gonna hate everything
about it and try to torpedo the whole
thing two of them are just going to go
along with it just because they are so
desperate for peace two are gonna check
out right so we're gonna
begin to spot each one of these kids and
how we can best love them because it's
going to be different for each one of
them but we're gonna need a professional
for that and that's just a party okay
that's just a part of moving forward I
just wouldn't do it without that
I totally agree so I'm telling you these
things tell me tell me what you're
thinking are you going okay cool that's
easy dude or oh geez like I need to
think this through
no um uh I think it sounds like really
greatly I didn't think about the
professional counseling part and I think
it's going to be huge
um and I know my oldest he he even told
me he can't wait until I have a
girlfriend so he can tease me for having
a girlfriend because I tease him for
having a girlfriend
and and do know this
children in in the situation like your
kids are in they will use very grown-up
words
they will nuzzle up to one or one or
both of you
this is a incred excruciatingly painful
situation for kids
and so even when even when 11 year olds
making jokes like that that 11 year old
is um desperately trying to make sure
y'all's relationship is okay
does that make you see what I'm saying
yeah absolutely and so any any res any
um dysregulation from kids
I'm going to give them a really gracious
pass for a while because their whole
world has exploded and they're going to
the mirror every day saying what did I
do what could I have done
what could I have done what could I have
done there's something that kids
experience um called the uh
reconciliation fantasy that is really
hard especially if you decide you're
getting a gauge or getting married
there's always this lingering sense in
the back of their mind that one day Mom
and Dad will get back together
and there's a there's another grief that
they experience after the initial
breakup when it becomes serious when
when Mom finally says hey I'm getting
married
then it becomes this oh this is forever
right kids don't have that that they
don't have that um
that sense of time yet
so all I have to say is this it's gonna
be really Rocky as smooth as you think
it is right now it's going to be Rocky
and that's okay it's just it's just
keeping space for it to be very uh
complicated
and we did uh I did end up buying uh
there's two books that you recommended a
while ago
um about the two households and how you
know Mom and Dad still love you guys
that kind of stuff
um and I've read that to them several
times and both uh me and their mom are
constantly telling them that you know
this is a an adult decision this had
nothing to do with you guys
um we both love you guys very very much
um it's just honestly excuse me
something uh that we felt was right that
is going to be better for them in the
long run as well I would give them an
opportunity to say words out of their
own mouth
sometimes when we get around our kids
we'll say things like Haze is on us we
did this and we explain stuff kids feel
stuff adults talk kids feel and so I
would whether that is once a week to
with your you know five-year-old to get
down literally lay down on your stomach
on your belly and y'all uh here She lays
down and you'll make an eye contact
maybe you're coloring and say hey I want
to hear from your heart
tell me what you're sad about with with
us getting a divorce let them use their
words ask that 11 year old like what do
you what have you it's been a few months
tell me about what you're sad about
and let them just talk and they may say
nothing nothing and you can say I'm sad
it's not what I thought was going to be
going in I'm sad about it and they need
to know that sometimes I'm sad and
sometimes I'm going to do something
different and that those two things
aren't linked but you see what I'm
saying but let's give them an
opportunity to not just hear hear hear
hear explanations from adults but that
their feelings are important too and
they get to speak out loud because
they're going to tell you things are
going to stun you and they have a levels
of insight that often my my daughter
after the shooting here in Nashville
recently she's seven and she explained
some things to me that I was absolutely
floored that she knew and I do this for
a living right I was I was stunned that
she knew some of the things that she
knew so all I'd say is give them a space
to talk about it it's just gonna be
tough one
okay cool
cool all right whenever you
um decide y'all are gonna um get married
and be all ew ew call in because I want
to talk to both of you I think that
would be make for a very fun phone call
that'd be fantastic thanks for calling
Sean I'm really grateful for you
everybody uh we'll be right back
[Music]
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself they help you set boundaries
and still have energy left to help
others without leaving yourself behind
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
totally online to fit into your schedule
you just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so find
more balance find Wellness with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go to Grace
in Austin Texas what's up Grace in the
5012 how we doing
I'm good talk to you it's great to talk
to you things okay
uh yeah it's a beautiful day excellent
yeah it is it is stunning out here in
Nashville today I'm glad that you all
need you all need a beautiful day
hey so what's up how can I help
okay so
um my question is
um how do I like release or let go of
this like perhaps unreasonable
bitterness that I have against my family
my parents specifically
um
and I know that's a super broad question
so I can explain it if you want can I
just start guessing things just kidding
yes of course explain it explain it okay
um so 10 years ago I was
oh my God I'm 2013 . I guess it is
okay yeah 10 years it's crazy
um wow what were you doing there
oh I was cheering on my mom she was
racing
oh my gosh
yeah
um and like I was at the finish line and
thankfully like didn't die yeah for real
hey can we just park on that sentence
that's an important sentence
okay yeah have you internalized that
over the last 10 years
I without gratefulness that I have okay
um it's a weird thing because
um you know no one thinks when they're
in like in Middle School that they're
just gonna go to a sporting event and
possibly like die but no did you did you
see things or did you hear things or did
you happen to leave yeah tell me what
you saw like
uh
I've never actually like told anyone
um
I'm gonna stop you there because I don't
want to be the first person in this in
this context yeah you can do that
somebody um up close but okay so keep
keep going here
so yeah I mean I saw all the things that
like the the news showed or wasn't
allowed to show honestly
um but anyway I over the last 10 years
I've done a lot of like work
to get rid of or try my best get rid of
like the
um physical post-traumatic symptoms I
guess you could say
um a lot of stuff started to present
itself like in the spring which was kind
of weird
um like a lack of sleep and all that and
all that was to be expected and we were
warned
um but I guess like 10 years later I'm
realizing that there's a lot of
bitterness I still have for the way that
my family like dealt with
um the situation afterwards I did get I
did get sent to a counselor because I
was honest with my family about like
what I saw and like when everyone was
telling us not to look in One Direction
we were running away like I was curious
so I looked and
um anyway uh so I went to a counselor
but in my head like growing up I had
heard over and over that like
that was weak or maybe I hadn't heard it
but I had internalized that
um that you go to a counselor if you
have a problem and I didn't think that I
had a problem like I I just thought I
would be able to move on
um and so I I didn't really like talk to
anyone about it I just
um now I'm realizing that I shoved it
down and I just
um I guess and now dealing with it 10
years later so it doesn't really go away
but um what did your what did your mom
and dad do that you're still so bitter
your family I think it's what they
didn't do
um tell me about that I
so
there was a lack of
conversations about it like we turned to
humor in my family which is really nice
in the moment but I think long term it
has done some damage and it's created
some coping mechanisms in me that like I
just blame on them and I just need to
take some like personal responsibility
for them because
now I'm in my 20s and I wanna tell me
what change that give me two things
you've done as coping mechanisms
um
I never talk about it
and then when I do I only talk about it
in like
trying to find a purpose in the bombing
like I'm just so obsessed just finding
the good in it I guess
um
um tell me though
what are some coping behaviors
oh okay are you restrictive with what
you need are you
um yeah I was just about to say that
yeah I developed like a really horrible
eating disorder
I was like
my fuel I guess
um yeah
and sorry I'm teetering on series
and I'm really if you were with me
um and you could feel safe
um I would push you a little bit further
but since we're on the phone you're
sitting by yourself and you can hear me
um but
your body can't feel this room right now
okay so I'm I am intentionally stopping
one or two
uh two questions short okay but I I know
that you can feel that I'm stopping too
yeah I can yeah because yeah so and
here's I want you to hear me say this
um and this is both a disarming thing
and this is also a frustrating thing for
you
the fact that I immediately picked this
isn't written down anywhere you didn't
to my knowledge you didn't put this in
your entry I didn't even read your
letter that you sent I just have a
little a clip
um the fact that I picked disorder
eating out of thin air
I want you to know this isn't the
you're you're on a long line of people
who've suffered awful things
yeah and did not have people around that
would
listen to right and left you to swim in
the middle of the ocean by yourself and
what's super frustrating is they all
look like they were swimming just fine
right next to you
yeah and they worked they're not they're
not either Grace they're not yeah but
they look like the craziest thing is I
just look around me and like I a few
other people in my family like were
there
and I just I look at them and I'm like
jealous almost of it's a mirage it's a
mirage it's a mirage it's a mirage
and good for you that you got addicted
to success
and not something else fair right yeah
definitely fair yeah so what's going on
now 10 years later is it media coverage
is it what what is what is bringing this
up now
well my parents did a good job of
covering shielding us from the media
that didn't want us to get obsessed with
it because they did hear that sometimes
people do turn to it just get obsessed
with the story I'm gonna tell you they
did the best they could with the info
they had and what they did was
absolutely backwards yeah completely
backwards okay completely backwards okay
um but we we can talk through that in a
second
um yeah or uh um now go ahead sorry
um I was just gonna say that now I
um actually qualified for the Boston
Marathon so running it in a week
foreign
so I just I kind of like I just wanted
something to be like mine out of this
you know yeah
um
and yeah
I just I'm setting my expectations like
moderate because who knows
um but I'm just excited that I have the
opportunity to go you know and like
I hope to make it good
this time it's okay grace no one's ever
told you this
it is okay to be terrified out of your
mind
and it's okay to be so scared that the
day before you get on that plane you
don't go
and it's also okay to go and to run not
your best time but to finish in a active
defiant so profound that few people will
ever understand
what you've done
yeah that's how
that's how it feels like a victory
already I guess yeah um it is I think
the reason why I like really wanted to
just like talk to someone about it is
because
not all aspects of the last 10 years
feel Victorious at all you know like and
I expected like 10 years later like why
can't this just be like done you know
because that because here's the deal you
you haven't dealt with it
yeah I just don't know how to start I
know and you don't have a picture of
what that looks like in your house
yeah I'm heartbroken for you
so can I use a
recent tragedy in in my neighborhood to
talk through how I dealt with it with my
little kids
yeah so I'm in Nashville so we just had
that shooting where that person went
inside and shot kids inside of a little
Christian School right
my seven-year-old and my 13 year old
my seven-year-old we laid down on our
tummies on our stomachs on our
trampoline
outside
and I asked her to tell me what she knew
and what she'd heard and she wasn't at
the school she was down the road but
that was going to be the school that was
her feeder school from her her Pre-K and
so she's had people so I asked her to
tell me everything she knew about
whatever she knew then I asked her to
tell me about her feelings
she said she was scared but she knew
what to do and then
she explained a few things to me on
active shooter training that I learned
in a SWAT Operation
and then I wept because I thought my
seven-year-old should not freaking know
this but I didn't hide it from her I let
her see me you see what I'm saying see
how different it is
yeah now I didn't let her watch the news
because she's seven
but there's a difference between trying
to Shield somebody and to age
appropriately let them feel and see what
grief looks like
and one step further
I've shown up to scenes and I have
things in my mind that will be there for
the rest of my life just like you right
right yeah the only difference is most
of mine not all but most of them I was
an adult you were a child and so your
body has stamped that
yeah and no adult came to rescue you
no yeah I mean they tried like hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold
to stop defending them
you've been defending them your whole
life
you have to stop it's not your job
like um I understand that I just I think
my problem with it is putting myself in
their shoes like there's no textbook for
that you know I don't know exactly here
here let me say this
we're not we're not going to blame them
as though there's some retribution or
some like
declaration of war
but we're also going to hold in the
other hand so we're not hating we're not
we're not going to war
but we're gonna hold in the other hand
I was 10.
and somebody that I know and that I love
should have hugged me and said you saw
horrible things tell me about it you're
you weren't safe then but you're safe
now
I'm gonna go to counseling with you
because I'm scared and when they notice
that their teenage daughter
was
skipping meals and losing weight that
they would say hey
I'm gonna come with you
I'm stopping all of our plans that we're
running to you see what I'm saying and
so there is in one hand no we're not
going to beat somebody up because they
were dealing with their own trauma I get
that
and
there was another way that could help it
dealt with it and you have to own both
yeah okay both things are true
you can still love love love them
because they did the best they could
with what they had with the tools they
had their tool kit and as a kid you
needed more
right okay and so now here we are we're
left with
um
you're in your 20s
yep and what am I going to do now right
yeah
yeah I feel like it's like the Forgotten
thing
um like none of my friends really
remember
um
I just feel like it's very Niche and I
have no one to like relate to about it
um not that I want a relatable problem I
guess no you decide to talk to so I'll
tell you the actual thing that happened
is niche
okay yeah actual thing
but trauma is not Niche at all
right
it's not
and so I'm going to give you a couple of
standard lines that are important grief
Demands a witness
you have to say the words out loud of
what you experienced and what you went
through
not with me but with somebody you care
and Trust And if that's a new counselor
that's a new counselor if that's your
mom and dad that's your mom and dad
if that's your sister that's your sister
but you have you can no longer try to
keep all of this bound and trapped in
your body because you're trying to
protect everybody around you
because when you were 10 you've got this
weird sense in your soul that you didn't
protect somebody
that you did something wrong that you
didn't do enough
how do you say that because I've
actually had this guilt for a while that
I ran away I know I know
Grace you were 10. yeah
if you ran up on a 10 year old right now
who is trying to help what would you
tell them to do
um like find cover get out of here yes
yeah cause you're 10. right
yeah it's unreasonable
um I know but the body does what it does
to keep us safe right right so
now there's some there's some pretty
clear research that says
um it's just been my personal experience
too
that just sitting down and Hauling off
and just saying here's everything from
start to finish about my trauma can
actually
re-traumatize your body in a weird way
so the first thing you're going to do is
you're going to get with somebody who's
a trauma specialist and you're gonna
they're gonna it's called seeking safety
you're gonna find a
you're going to teach your body ways to
slowly slowly enter some of these uh
thoughts and memories and
not get overwhelmed by them
okay okay and it's it's the same as
before you run the Boston Marathon you
gotta run two miles it's that and you're
there's it's it's actually pretty it's a
pretty standard series of we're gonna
meet for three or four times and
practice a couple of ways to
slow our bodies down when it starts to
gear up and there's going to be a couple
of sessions that are in Hell there's
gonna be a couple of sessions and how do
we make a light of this new world how do
we go make meaning of all this
right you're trying to make meaning
you're trying to
um
here's what you've done in a in such a
beautifully eloquent way
you have laid all the ingredients out
for an incredible
um
Texas catfish dinner
and you've got all the people at your
house
and you've got all the lines and bait
you just haven't gone fishing yet
okay so you're trying to make meaning of
something that you haven't fully
processed yet you're holding a 10 year
old accountable for her actions when the
adults in the world around her
left her trying to figure out what to do
next because they they were too busy
trying to survive too
okay
and now you're doing an incredibly Brave
thing
by going back to ground zero and saying
I I won't be conquered by this
this will be a Monumental moment for you
if you don't go through it or if you do
or if you do but here's the thing it's
not Rocky 4 like this isn't going to be
the it's not gonna heal you it's not
everything's not gonna be roses and
butterflies after this
go ahead and do what
I was just gonna say that's what I
realized from like training for this and
like the reality is the fact that like
what's going on inside my head hasn't
changed like yeah I'm ready and I'm fit
and I'm good to run this Marathon
um and I'm excited but I was like oh
wait I'm actually not feeling better
wait nothing's changed in in like I say
this all the time when I'm talking to
like business owners and it sounds trite
and cheesy you get to see it in as close
up as possible which is achievement
never heals you
nope right and you were about to do the
ultimate achievement the ultimate
display of bravery and
um middle fingers to your trauma
and it's still you're gonna cross that
Finish Line you're gonna be so thankful
and then you are still going to look to
your right and left
yep right
you're still gonna look to your right or
left
yep
don't let that stop you because this
will be this can be a
unbelievably powerful platform from
which to jump off of to go get well
yeah
but at some point you're gonna find
yourself sit in a circle there in Austin
with a couple of other survivors of
things
and you're going to find out you'll have
very different stories but very similar
lives
and you're gonna have
achieved and accomplished and sought
control over
and for the first time you're going to
feel safe enough
after a couple of sessions with a
professional
maybe more than a couple you're going to
feel safe enough to finally open your
hands and let go
and then in the safety of those people
who've been there to hell and back
yeah we're just at different coasts
you're gonna find Solid Ground for the
first time
since you were 10 or 11.
you'll have bouts of anger with your
parents you're gonna have bouts of great
peace and forgiveness with your family
all the things
I'll be so so I am I'm just blown away
by how proud I am of you
you are stronger than most of us will
ever ever know
so go run your race and if you get close
to it you just can't awesome you got
this far I will high five you all the
way
but if you go through it and you finish
the race
finish it
then you go home
and you exhale
then you look in the mirror and you can
say all right Grace now it's time
you're gonna make that phone call
and you're gonna sit down with somebody
and say I need to talk about some things
I saw when I was 10.
they still haunt me now
and I need some help teaching my body
that I wasn't okay then
but I'm okay now
I wasn't safe then but I'm safe now
and then we'll be about making meaning
so proud of you Grace let me know shoot
me a note when you finish when you cross
that finish line or if you decide to not
run whatever you decide to do let me
know we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here
I fell through a glitch in The Matrix
this is my job I get to have this show
do this show walk alongside each one of
you as a career this is what I do and I
have a blast doing it and me and the
team were so thankful for all of you for
being a part of our show whether you're
one of the original 17 or you're one of
the millions that's come since then we
are so grateful for you and we want to
put together the best possible show that
we can so if you're one of The Originals
or if you're brand new we want your
feedback tell us what you love about the
show what you hate about the show would
you like to see more of what you like to
hear more of and what you want us to
never do again you can email us at
askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's ask
John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right we are back it's time for
facts all your friends let's do it
[Music]
the official song of NASCAR
is it no all right we're gonna give you
today I'm gonna give you four steps what
to do when the whole world has lost its
mind
and you find yourself just barely
hanging on
um we had another segment to discuss
today and I got up super early this
morning just spinning spinning spinning
spinning sat down and said I didn't put
all this on paper here
um there's so much uh and I'm just
thinking about my neighborhood so much
here in Nashville
um
everybody's still healing everybody
still yelling the politicians in the
city have just I don't I don't have the
words for it just lost their minds just
lost their minds just bananas
um politics across the country I don't
care who you are
if you stop for a second and turn the
radio off
turn the TV off and you just roll your
window down and you're driving down the
road
you're being honest
both parties are insane insane
Madness
I was with some folks who are close
friends of mine who are different
politically this weekend on both sides
of the aisle
the most common reframe refrain was
I don't know who my party is anymore
they're insane you just regular old
neighbors regular good folks
foreign
I see tons of cowardice and frightened
and fear my neighbors and my friends and
across the country I'm gonna be real
honest with you this is just me being
vulnerable
seems cowardice when I look in the
mirror
I've seen fear when I look in the mirror
just I got two little kids man I brought
him into this mess
and I'm not just talking about Nashville
I'm talking about politics across the
country I'm talking about
um all the chaos then you step back and
you hear about like China's moves to
replace the dollar and shifting Global
priorities you can Ukraine war it's on
and on and on and then at home we've got
kids and grades and inflation it's too
expensive to move but it's I don't have
enough money in my in my current job all
of it
and if we're honest we're trying to do
two things one of two things I mean
we're either going to double down what
we know and just try to do whatever we
were already doing faster or with more
Force more aggressively right or more
recklessly
which by the way that's Insanity it's
Madness to keep doing the same thing
just faster and harder when you get
stuck whenever you find yourself in your
in your tires are in mud
just jamming on the gas just digs a huge
hole that you for sure are going to get
out of now
and that's what we're doing with our
lives
we're just getting angrier and more
frustrated and going and going and going
and going and yelling and frazzled or
just checking out we're done I'm out I'm
gonna have one more drink and one more
drink
I'm gonna watch one more Netflix episode
I'm gonna get super excited about the
next series and spend all my time
talking about the next series the next
series because I've outsourced my lives
I'm done living them so I'm just gonna
let Ted lasso and let him live life for
me
I'm just gonna let office reruns that
I've already watched 700 times I'm gonna
let them have friendships in Romance
enjoy and laughter and work hijinks
because I'm I'm done with my life I've
just cashed out
think of it like being in an aquarium
you're in an aquarium and there's water
pouring in and there's water the water
level is rising okay we have voices on
the right telling us we need to suck it
up and just learn how to swim we have
voices on the left just wanting to just
to focus on the stories about who's
dumping the water
and we have voices telling us
um from above that we need to build a
better and New Foundation at the bottom
of this aquarium and we have voices
below us telling us this is the way it's
always been and we're trapped and it's
all coming down and I want us just to
look around these narratives aren't
working even if there's truth in each
one of them it's not helping people
it's not
and I want to propose something new
let's just get out of the aquarium
let's just get out
just be done with it not worry about
swimming or build whatever let's just
get out
because what you need right now is not
another new diet another scam not
another scroll in the news media by the
way the news stations do not care about
you they want your clicks and they want
your attention they want you to keep
spending your money they don't care
about you
politicians don't care about you they
want to keep their jobs and their power
to keep on spending your money that is
it
that's it
so what do we do
I'm gonna give you four steps on what do
you do when you feel out of control some
of these are short-term like you can do
them right now some of these are going
to be long term it might take you one
two several years
okay
but there's clear research that when
somebody finally gets the courage to
call a counselor
they actually start feeling better
when somebody gets an actual plan in
front of them and they say this plan
works and there's a line of people
who've done that plan and say hey this
this one works
that you actually stand taller you feel
better
be on a path having a direction is key
even if you're not all the way there
even if you're just starting okay and by
the way these things aren't great and
they are not fun
in fact initially they are not awesome
they're going to feel terrible some of
these are going to feel terrible you're
going to feel guilty you're going to say
things like I can't or I don't know how
here's what's beautiful about them I'm
not uh giving you some hack I'm not
running up a gimmick
I'm just telling you the truth like I
always do on the show
it's telling you the truth
and by the way this is a conversation I
had with myself at four or five this
morning
because I got up just spinning just
spinning this morning
when things are hopelessly
out of control it feels Bleak or it
feels dark
we are going to solve for Freedom here's
what that means that is not
um American flag under ruse and like an
eagle going across this that's not what
I'm talking about
we are trapped chained to things we are
stuck in the aquarium so we're going to
look at the four ways we are chained to
the aquarium and we're going to cut the
chains
okay
number one
if you owe somebody money you can't just
move you can't get out of your abusive
job you can't get out of your parents
basement you can't look at your husband
and say you stop hitting or cheating on
me or I'm gone can't do that
because Ford Motor companies telling you
what you're doing tomorrow your mortgage
company is telling you what you're going
to do tomorrow
Visa is telling you what you're going to
do tomorrow you are chained inside of
that aquarium you can't move
and yes I'm biased I work at Ramsey
Solutions we do we help people get out
of debt
doesn't matter doesn't mean it's not
true
and I take a more psychological angle
your body will not let you rest if
somebody else can just snatch your house
from you or just snatch your
transportation from you or just snatch
your food from you it won't let you
so stop pretending like you got a great
deal on a thing that you don't have to
pay for for 12 months whatever it's just
a couch
don't oh pay every debt off that you owe
pay them all off
this is a massive chain around your neck
pay it off pay it off all of them get
insane about it get radical about it
your life depends on it
and by the way while we're here stop
waiting for the government to pay off
your debts for you quit it pay them off
you signed your name I had to pay off
six figures of them
did I know what I was signing no but I
did I put my name on it as an 18 year
old and a 19 year old and a 20 year old
and a 25 year old I did it I did it
so I'm gonna pay them off I'm gonna stop
waiting on the government deal it like
an adult does it suck yes is it the
worst yes do it
my wife and I had to sell our nice house
and move into a tiny little apartment in
a dorm with a kid pay them off whatever
it takes whatever it takes pay him off
number two time we use our calendars as
a as a proxy for self-worth Monday night
is sports practice Tuesday is piano or
guitar Wednesday night is soccer
Thursday night is youth group or dance
Friday nights hang out with friends
Saturday night Saturdays are all day
sporting events and then hanging out
with friends Sunday is church or more
games or both plus schooling plus
commuting plus all the yoga and the
appointments at 1.5 hour workout
programs or Netflix shows or baseball
games stop stop you become a slave to
your calendar quit
quit
I was talking to somebody recently not
on air they needed to go to inpatient
treatment
for some significant trauma there's a
really incredible Brave person I was
talking with
their first response was but there's so
many things I've got to do who's going
to get them done
calendar
get with your cat with your spouse and
begin canceling things
just cancel just stop
create a day with nothing no plans no
electronics create a day or two for
hosting just hanging out with friends
and family tell them to bring their
whatever crap they have in the fridge
just bring it over half a two liter of
what bring it over I don't care old wine
bring it over
try one sport and one lesson and that's
it that's it your kids are gonna be fine
if you drive six hours on a Saturday for
a nine-year-old soccer game
stop just stop
just stop
ask yourself is is your job worth dying
for
because for Bunches of you it's killing
you
and this one's hard for me because I am
a to the death workaholic
I am
I work to prove my self-worth and so
this one's hard for me
you are not your busy calendar a full
calendar does not mean a full life it
means you're choosing to distract
yourself from living a full life you're
running and running away number three
clutter junk
stuff everywhere okay so real quick in
18 seconds
our bodies are designed to live in a
world of scarcity
it's designed to eat with whatever you
can get your hands on
it's designed to if you've got water I'm
gonna drink some waterlogged you find a
mate we are going to make make me
designed for scarcity and then boom
overnight we have
hacked the supply chains for food and
mates and everything they're everywhere
everything's everywhere
and then we also my granddad
um came out of the Great Depression
and he straightened up nails
because he had to my grandmother saved
string that came off of like clothes
because they had to they didn't couldn't
just go to the store and buy some
because there was no store and there was
no things and there was no money to buy
it if there had been in store so we've
got these bodies who are designed for
scarcity that are designed for scarcity
and then we have a picture one or two
generations away of people who saved
nails
and we have hit the pendulum so far that
we try to insulate ourselves from the
next big whatever with stuff more
clothes more shoes more bicycles more
weight equipment more workout programs
more digital clutter more passwords more
logins more whatever
our culture has no breaks on it when it
comes to this one magic word enough we
know how to do it
just start getting rid of stuff
go room by room make it a five month
transformation make it a 30-day
transformation my friends Joshua Fields
Milburn and Ryan Nicodemus and TK
Coleman they the minimalist they have a
challenge I think it's a third day
challenge where just on day one give
away one thing on day two give away two
things day three give away three things
by the time you get to the end of the
month 30 days or 31 days you're giving
away 30 things and over the course of
that month it's add up to a ton of stuff
you've given away
close
collections one day these Beanie Babies
are going to come back they're not
they're not coming back stop
your life
pair down your life pair down your life
paired on your life
closets or garages our attics our
storage spaces
our bank accounts our laptops it's
insanity
get rid of the Clutter
fourth
this is a whole book read Nidra to
Webb's book called Boundaries find
boundaries find peace
my friend Henry clouds got book out
boundaries it's Masterpiece awesome
who is telling you what you have to do
with your life your parents your in-laws
your abusive spouse your old professor
ask yourself this terrifying question
what do I want with my life
and then ask yourself this other scary
question what do I want this month and
then ask yourself an even more
terrifying question and if you're
married do it with your spouse tomorrow
what do I want for today
and what is happening today that's going
to get me to this life that I want
this is solving for freedom
with your money with your time with your
clutter your boundaries
solve for it
it's all for freedom
here's a bonus one phone a friend
get a friend to work through this with
you but you're married whether you're 18
whether you're 72 call a friend
the world's gonna go bananas and we've
lived in a pocket of history when things
have been relatively stable especially
for large swaths of the West those days
may be over
not in a bad dramatic way just we've had
some pretty stable times
some stable decades
I expect Ascension I expect chaos I
expect people to be self-serving I can't
do anything about them but I can't
control me I'm gonna look at every angle
of my life and solve for Freedom
especially in those four areas
let me get out of the aquarium as
quickly as possible and if this sends a
sense of panicky in you good good
leave work early and sit down with your
husband or your wife and say we're gonna
do this now
and on the way you're going to find grit
and strength and resilience that you did
not know you had
you're gonna find out that you can do
anything
then
you will be truly
free
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show the
great Neil Diamond in his
karaoke classic
where it began
I can't begin to knowing
but then I know it's growing strong
was in the spring and spring became the
summer who'd have believed you'd come
along
hands touching hands reaching out
touching me touching you yeah this is
for sure an HR violation Sweet Caroline
Good Times never seem so good
so good so good I've been inclined to
believe they never would but now I
and this song goes on and on and on love
you guys stay in school don't do drugs
[Music]